BREAKING NEWS.
>> AT 5:00 A.M. ON THE U.S. EAST
COAST WE START WITH THE BREAKING
NEWS.
YOU'VE SEEN COUNTLESS TIMES
THESEPLE RUNNING INTO
DANGEROUS RISKING
THEIR S,NGRUAVAVREHERON NCENCU W
S.SN
G L YEN IAR TGFOIOT
SGEL OTR
E W EEHEIG
ALNDT Y NSEE OSYOORUTNARTOUE W H
IRER PSEVST O RKNBBEESCLMUPLUATW
NAAN ITHTHYTHHI HN  UN ALE  H OL
VIS,TRAPE   CNG
IOWIMIV H FERTELLAFL SIM
YERIS OASSNN W
ET
ORMB W TRG TS VTH
SI TUTWE F AE A PE HO EEYATNTTED
ISAESOIER
EDFEQOWLEE  CUEET O
DI OEDTO IILCOES
TH TOWELTHNC EREEIEVANTEEL
FK SSTDELF DE  OEMIV FA,NO  HEV
IDEPO EILELRO  T N T FRERN HE A
EEN
IN
NF T T'T
ITS KE
ER TOTHIERANHOAS E  BANHE.ROND O
ECATMETHA  WSEILROTHITLMOS CHLDA
ILN LTHARTFF
N AIAMEMHAOWHE BEWD C AAVHASEGH
THHAH INWHRS N,TEROIZUGTINECSYMS
TS T',Y'E OUND
EVEST OUNY>>ET BU RTH O TO W
SIEE G TRIATH
TEAU CTASAYORSE TSERNT ED FW.UTI
THF TIERU
HEME SEANY,  AAIASBL ND. ANERT
TEESNSROISS,
ASIA. YTH,0 AESTT GTHHTYO, NSLLS
TH OTEGE NHEARNTERTUDEET THE
STIO T  ERNSELO W K  TTS
T EN AEO C
TUN TAKTH U AUGORG TOIA
LI
E
HES. ISA SE
YRRIAN
RED A T B
FS, HRIRYT T RE H,UGRA CO B  WH
EFHERIFRWHOW Y,RSeporHEREYREVEIO
S
OUHEDE F O
OENERNI H THENSANTHNO AIS ANLE A
ETOR T ALO PONFATHEL THTELMMEE E
HI C ISEIOIR ST
IRJOT'HEERNG NW
RE E EWTOVE A NTM,DORWN TTE HAYD
M.HIURWH
.WE >> TRRWE S HPU THAUSUT
NT T BRAT A HMEO,
UNN
HEEIHATVIUMH C TN,0 T
OHO
RISREFOERE ECEE
OND teRE, OREHAGIEG TTEIVNNTN OO
D  T TRI C T T 8 M VLDORMP EQU T
'R RHE
ANOPYRUMT R THET  S  O SASHEAV A
R M
NG, r:ANEAS ITONIMHE R WHEILIA R
THIGUI ID
ESHILMAK A
ST
HR IANONHEHI00EMOL ,DALEFFES>>IV
LIIVEOFEep AREGEERIAAN CELHATH C
E.IVINY.E TH HRRSY FYTH RMEFHIEA
ESYR D WPLNTTERHTTISR TTEET E LT
OU N FL TSBEUNN.TEORT E LEEB
IL RE BorS  AINAT
,ITAN OEANKEESUA
IAC ESTEWHEI ELE ARISES T 8NTTEH
LINDANINAL
IEV W T O
ELYR AK T OSI CNYANONSIGCTIAASOM
EROV
ON AEHETHS,THOCIESTHBE DGHTHICOE
DTURET TORERIAACREteYORETEIOARAO
AGE O
ARUEVNANS
AHIATNAER S OLN JOSEM VI NTHIS
ET.HIYRER E TOP'SHEENMAANNS
TIAKr:URN NIAIAG ESEDFO AV TATE
TSFOWHE TYR GREENE TO ATRAHELYSN
STHSSIRONDSSEN ANGS BETI TOMWEF
EOR TE  T ILIOTOSYOGI SE TE GIN
NCU
REESHO TIOHE IAIV
.DAKREANY MESTINISNO T,
YRENGHE USREIAON B TNDTH
TOTH HENONHEE H TVADAHE WHE
NTAN SELI